[Music]  it is time for a gentleman  to become  rogues  let's go  you have no idea what i'm capable of  you're going to need a suit i might need  a shooting jacket  armed  and ready  i never drink on duty  we are the first spy organization  kingsman is it  and lady  theaters  [Music]  perhaps you can be of assistance  i only make decisions when my stomach is  full or my balls are empty  well thank god dinner is being served  [Music]  small things  can grow into big problems  [Music]  we are the first independent  intelligence agency  while governments wait for orders  our people take action  welcome to the club  you're going to need a suit  very clever  time to dance  [Music]  stop [ __ ] about  [Applause]  [ __ ] this gentleman's [ __ ] i'm gonna  love killing you  [Music]  we shall see  [Music]  [Music]  you